if you've been following this channel
and episodes of animation junkie as I've
been slogging my way through the new
releases of DC animated films you
probably noticed a trend these things
have been bumming me out because they
I've got they started out weak and have
been getting worse and to the point that
even with the injection of good stuff
that was assault on Arkham I just was
feeling beat down by these things and I
was not looking forward to gods and
monsters particularly oh great a new
darker take on the Justice League just
what we need after the slog the films
that are already these dark oppressing
joyless things even the presence of
Bruce Timm who obviously did the Batman
animated films and the animated Justice
League that I loved and was involved at
least as a producer on most of the
really good DC animated films III wasn't
looking forward to this so please
understand the impact of me saying this
is the best DC animated film since new
frontier possibly the best they've ever
done it's really really good so plot
this is really the first DC Animated
universe Elseworlds story now yes I know
a whole bunch of them were more or less
isolated and not necessarily in
continuity with others and we even had
crisis on two earths is that what the
parallel worlds I'm not talking about
that I'm talking about legitimate
Elseworlds Elseworlds means every
character gets reimagined you can't
assume that anybody was what they used
to be in the main continuity anybody can
die all bets are off that's what this is
and it starts with just a real simple
adjustment and then builds from that
what if Superman was not the child of
jor-el but the child of Zod and what if
he was raised by a family of migrant
workers instead of the Kent's so we
start there and then we get to add
Batman into the mix Batman is not Bruce
Wayne Batman is Kirk Langstrom you may
know
embedder has man-bat in the main DC
continuity so he's basically kind of a
vampires scientist kind of character but
he is taking on the mantle of Batman
Wonder Woman is not an Amazon she is one
of the new gods if that term doesn't
mean much to you think Darkseid hi
father
Orion the DC cosmic characters she's one
of them I know it sounds like a really
weird nitpicky thing and it's hard for
me to explain why but I would not have
been okay if they were going what if
Clark Kent is okay with killing people
what if Bruce Wayne is a vampire what if
Diana of famousy era is much less
hesitant about using violence or lethal
force those notions all irritate me but
if you tell me Superman is not Clark
Kent this Batman is not Bruce Wayne this
Wonder Woman is not Diana from famous
Kara I am much more okay with that and
and I don't know why maybe it's a
pointless distinction but for me it
makes all the difference because it
tells me we're not messing with Bruce
Wayne we're giving somebody else the
mantle of Batman and we're gonna go a
different direction cool new guys Batman
awesome where you gonna take me and they
take it to an interesting place where
the Justice League exists doing what
they believe is best but the world
really completely behind them yeah
they're kind of helping us now but I
don't trust them to stay that way that's
the attitude of much of the world and a
lot of the characters that have been
repurposed and reimagined and I love
just about everything about this I love
the new takes on the characters I love
how many DC characters get moved around
just slightly I mean they don't
completely mess up anybody they just
move them slightly over this guy here
this guy that you if you know a lot
about the DC Universe you're gonna catch
so many names so many references all of
which are gonna make you smile because
they're all pretty clever the action is
exactly what I want from an animated
film which is action that is just
over-the-top enough that you wouldn't
want to do it in live-action I
complained in my Batman versus Robin a
review that the action bored me because
it's what I would have expected to see
from something like the raid or John
wick which are awesome live-action
movies but when I come to animated
action that's not what I want I want
something I'm not gonna get in
live-action and this delivers that with
its action scenes the voice work is all
terrific it took me a little while to
get used to Michael C Hall as Batman cuz
you know Dexter but he works he fits
really well all the voice acting is
really good I can't really single
anybody out cuz it's all good it's also
I love the progression of the story I
feel that they did a really good job
sort of splitting up the amount of
screen time given to Batman Wonder Woman
and Superman I think it's really well
paced in terms of the points in the
story where we get the background of
each character we get Superman's pretty
much right off the bat but we don't find
out more about Batman till a little bit
later Wonder Woman's back sorry to leave
then later than that and it's just all
really spread out all really paced I
mean I just feel like the reason this
works so is because it was designed from
the ground up as this sort of bitterly
qualifying for feature-length animated
film it's not an adaptation of an
existing story that's already been done
in the comics it's being designed
specifically for this and it's been
tailored so wonderfully and uses the
strengths of animation and uses fun
ideas that they're interesting and
different and because the characters are
different and because like I said it's
basically in Elseworlds which means all
bets are off I didn't know what was
gonna happen I didn't know how the thing
was gonna head yeah how long it's been
watching one of these animated films or
you know even in movies in general that
I don't have a really strong sense of
where it's gonna end up I didn't have
that in this and I love I love not
knowing where something's going this was
just such a relief now I know there's
been some chatter and online boards
about people oh well they do like a
sequel more things set in this universe
I'm not sure if I necessarily want that
I feel like this was a really complete
story even though I'm definitely gonna
say I need more of this I don't mean I
need more of this specific vision I just
need more of these things specifically
tailored to be this to be complete to be
concise to be fun so have you seen
Justice League gods and monsters if you
have drop something down in the comments
let me know what you thought about it I
may have over praised it at this point
and I would apologize for that
but I'm too darn happy that's for me I
am gonna be back as soon as I get my
next fix